what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the audacity and where I talk about all
the women that have had the audacity on
Twitter today before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started
um so number one audacity go ahead
I'm sitting here in my car having posted
birthday cards to my twin sons who the
family court and its wisdom has um
prevented me from having anything to do
with after a two-year battle they've
admitted that although I did nothing
wrong and the DV was a lie and
everything else was a [__] lie that
I've been gone for so long from their
lives that it's now in their best
interest that their father has nothing
to do with them
reconciliation counseling was deemed
unsuitable as the mother would not
cooperate with it so the mother should
get Soul custody tell me how that works
hey how is that not [__] corrupt
this country is a [__] disgrace nine
fathers a day kill themselves because of
this [__] you'd remove our sons and
daughters from us and treat us like
we're nothing but [__] ATMs
you you're a disgrace if you are
anything to do with or support the
family court in any way may you burn in
hell
because that is what awaits you when you
stand before our Lord and my judgment
to my sons I love you dearly I've never
known such heartache as not being able
to contact you even though the court
admits I did nothing wrong at all
nothing wrong nothing against me
substantiated nothing proven I did
nothing wrong it is deemed that I am
better to be removed from your lives I
hope that you get your your CR your
birthday cards my boys I very much doubt
they'll be handed on to you
I love you my sons the pain and anguish
that I feel every day
because I can't see you is killing me
I know you're living with an abuser and
it's breaking my heart because there's
nothing I can do about it I tried
everything to fix this situation
and I couldn't I failed and for that I
beg you forgiveness my boys I love you
forever bye
and that's the thing like a lot of
people don't realize just how corrupt
this like the court system is where
there are good Dads that want to be a
part of their kids lives um that women
can openly lie about and especially in
the UK it is so bad here because you get
a free lawyer if you accuse a guy of
abuse and remember when they implemented
this law that you get a free lawyer if
you accuse a guy of abuse abuse
accusations went up 300 so when Destiny
and some of the other reaction channels
um that don't know anything they never
talk to anyone in the system and when
they do they don't believe them say this
is not a problem the men just aren't
fighting for their kids it's like nine
men a day commit suicide because they
they can't see their children
um and remember that leads to every
problem that we have in society
homelessness
um kids running away from home dropping
out of school most grapists came from
single parent home single mother homes
80 percent of the prison population came
from single mother homes like they they
allow women to accuse men and get away
with it so I actually think it's so
disgusting and I think a woman I
genuinely feel so strongly about this
that I think that a woman that doesn't
let the dad see his kid should face jail
time I think it should be that serious
because the consequences are that
serious the consequences for someone not
having their dad in their life are
serious enough that
um they're more likely to be sexually
abused and the more Mo you know is the
most likely person to sexually abuse a
child the the stepdad
um so you're putting your kid in a
situation where there they could be
abused by someone else they could they
could go to prison grape someone
homelessness and or just have I mean how
many mental freaking issues does our
generation have or like you know as much
as I make fun of the women that say I
had all this trauma in childhood like I
do think it comes from somewhere and it
comes from selfish mothers that kick the
dad out of the home and I think it's
that serious that they should face jail
time
um okay so the next woman that had the
audacity is a Florida substitute teacher
arrested for letting a seventh grader
hit her vape and when asked about it she
said I was just trying to fit in and we
wonder why let's look at the comments at
least it ain't meth
um really good girl even I ignore these
youngins asking for the links in the
threat I don't know what that says uh
yeah basically though yeah can you
imagine sending your kid to school and
they're vaping from a teacher it's
actually weird in hindsight when I think
of some of like the things that teachers
used to say to us or talk about like
there are teachers that definitely
talked like in class not not to me
because I I was kind of lame
um but but um other like kids in class
about like drinking party like and I'm
just like I would kill I would kill
someone if they were talking to my kid
about that like that is crazy they are
not adults
um okay New York Post a widow who wrote
grief book after husband died was
charged with his murder so this woman
right here wrote a book
um about grief when allegedly you click
the link let's see what happened
allegedly she killed her husband all
right
um let's see here we go a mom who wrote
children's book about dealing with grief
following her husband's death has been
charged with his Murder She allegedly
killing him with fentanyl
um if she's accused of poisoning her
husband at their home in Utah
almost a year to the day after Eric's
death Corey published the book are you
with me to help kids cope with death of
a loved one
oh they are daspy that's what they say
they say just found it find a good woman
in the book Corey wrote dedicated to my
amazing husband and a wonderful father
yo she killed him
can you imagine killing looking for a
great deal on your car and then writing
not only killing someone right she wrote
a book about the grief she was
okay let's go to the next one
I wonder how long I've been I bet he
doesn't get life in prison I bet you she
don't I bet you she doesn't hi yeah so
another woman having the audacity to be
this fat now women are more obese than
men that is a fact I'd like all the fact
Checkers to fact check that this is more
common for women please press play
I think it should be illegal to walk
outside when you're that fat
no okay I swear because all right people
say this doesn't affect anybody okay
when you're that fat just it only
affects yourself no because I have to
look at you so now I'm being traumatized
with your roles out and why would she
wear that can we pull back the outfit
why would you wear that outfit my mom
always told me and I told her she was
judgmental when I was a kid all right
she said that you have to earn a bikini
at the at the beach all right yeah and
you're telling me but she couldn't find
anything a little more flattering
nothing like why are we trying to show
this off you couldn't you couldn't get
like a nice dress like why does
everybody have to see your roles like
she knows what she's doing it's not like
she doesn't know her gut is out like
that and at the rate she's at you're
gonna be dead by 40. is that the life
that we want I honestly I think that fat
people
um shouldn't be allowed on the covers of
magazines because that is promoting an
eating disorder
um I also think that we shouldn't make
clothes for look it I she tweeted this
and I thought this is a great Point
let's not make clothes for go up go up
she said no up not down uh is it should
be illegal to make clothing this big I
think so too I think so too you know if
you know you can't buy clothes unless
you stay in a certain shape that'd be a
great incentive for society but you know
she'd probably just stretch him out
honestly like the clothes just gets
smaller okay keep go to the next one all
right Daily Loud a young woman from
England makes men submit a 500 word
essay to date her asking for an essay is
definitely a good way of weeding out
what you don't want yeah
um what would you what would you do if
you saw this King you write in the essay
chat GPT
sir
guys but it's like like women do this
they put these like crazy high standards
and say oh well it's eliminating all the
men that I don't want but it's like if
you gotten the results you wanted ask it
like it'd be one thing if you're like a
21 year old virgin but she looks like
she's like 30 like what I mean she's not
ugly but it's like can we stop acting
like we're hot [__] you're just a normal
chick anyways go to the next women just
have the audacity oh this I thought was
so funny
Scott Adams can you zoom in at all or no
um Scott Adams made a cartoon all right
and it says
um what are you looking for in a life
partner so that's the girl on the left
and he said I want someone exactly like
you and she says Ah and on the right he
says but less ran through wait wait what
oh that is so funny
um we say ran through I love it I love
him or the comments yeah funny guy funny
guy oh yeah so um as you know women's
sports I have I have a lot of respect
for uh women's sports and I'll say this
okay I am
so I've been an athlete since I was I
don't know I think I started playing
volleyball in fifth grade basketball I
don't know second third grade so I I've
literally cannot remember a time in my
life where I did not play sports sports
have genuinely meant so freaking much to
me and
um when you know so when I was like I
don't know 12 years old I started doing
travel volleyball and basketball so I'd
go to school I would do a two-hour
basketball practice then I would do a
three hour volleyball practice and there
would be an hour drive in between each
and I would come home at like 11 o'clock
at night get up the next day go back to
school same thing um on top of that I
went to college and I played three
Sports in college I played volleyball I
played basketball and I ran track
um we went to the ncaas
um you know I was freshman of the year I
was all conference I I really um I was
pretty successful when it comes to
Sports on top of that I got a pro
contract offer to me in the fall and I
played volleyball here in England and
what people don't realize is women's
sports we are some of the hardest
working people because there is no money
in women's sports none there is no end
goal of you can win this or get this it
you do it because you love it you love
being a part of a team and you like to
work hard and so I always say I have so
much respect for women that do Sports
until they do [__] like this they do
[__] like this all right so there's this
WNBA player this WNBA player all right
can you click the the right picture the
right basketball star 6A WNBA player
Elizabeth cam badge announces her only
fans so let me get this straight with
ladies we have gotten to the point we
have been begging men to respect our
Sports have we not just respect our
Sports equal pay all this and now you
get to the highest level become an elite
athlete one of the best probably to have
ever played the game like if you make it
to that level you were one of the best
ever in history and what what do you do
with this you get naked it's like how
can we keep saying men respect us when
we get naked every time they try to
what's what's the other thing in the
Tweet uh yeah WNBA players should sell
Nudes on lives
wait WNBA players should sell nudes
online that line that's the only fans
they'll ever have
yeah okay that's what I'm saying you
can't even say we do it for the
attention because nobody is at our games
none like we literally do it for nothing
they finally realized that nobody
watches women's sports yeah only way oh
and now they take the accountability off
of women it's the only way they can make
money you can make some money all right
just not good money all right but there
are people at McDonald's that keep
working at McDonald's without taking off
their clothes so it's not really an
excuse now this is an example of how
older women just start to get crazy when
they don't have a man to lead them in
life um so Gwyneth Paltrow just endorsed
150 vibrators to wear around your neck
you can wear it as jewelry or use it as
a sex toy can you imagine going on a
date do you think you would notice
yeah like why are we not can we just go
to them is there anything else or is
that the last one
um all right guys thank you for watching
The Audacity where we go over all the
women that just had the audacity
um this week
I'm so tired of this clown world this is
nuts but let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time